let me jump to the story uh from the new
york times alaska's voters will try out
changes to primary and special elections
so
they've got a ranked choice voting
and uh well they say voters in alaska on
tuesday will test for the first time a
new ranked choice system for a general
election in a special race for the state
single house seat and they will take
part in the state's new open primary
system which was first deployed during a
special house primary in june that
combination right there sounds like
a
let's put it this way we're not changing
the elections we're making it better
they changed the rules
open primaries i think are bad i used to
not understand why it mattered now i
totally get it because democrats can
vote in the republican primary to
sabotage the republican party so that
when it comes to the general nobody
wants to vote for the republican like if
the democrats vote for liz cheney and
she ends up winning republicans are
going to be like whatever and then a
democrat wins wyoming that'd be crazy
now we have ranked choice voting i'm
actually
i've been a fan of it for a while but
one thing interesting that comes up with
the way they're doing it now to consider
it is widely believed or actually jack
was mentioning it just before the show
that this is going to help murkowski
maintain her seat do you want to explain
because in ranked choice voting if
someone doesn't break the threshold then
it then they start counting the second
choice votes and so this will end up so
if all of your maga vote for example is
targeted to one candidate and then
they're never going to say the
establishment candidate as number two
you'll you will always see democrats or
soft conservatives soft republicans uh
your one of fours or even your 404s who
are more establishment types they will
put murkowski as their second choice so
she'll pick up a wider swath of voters
meanwhile a mega conservative is never
going to say they want a democrat as
their second choice but so so in we're
in a primary right now so people aren't
voting for
democrat they're voting for just the
republicans
wouldn't they just be more does it only
apply to does it only apply to the
primary well no no but here's my point
for now
wouldn't more people be like okay well
you know this candidate's not likely
going to win but they're my first pick
and then i guess if i had to take
murkowski in it as my fifth choice i
would
and i feel like in a primary it's open
primary which is the biggest risk right
if you if you do rank choice voting yeah
you're gonna get all the populists being
like man i really would prefer this guy
right here they might think he's not
going to win so i can't vote for him
with ranked choice voting they'll be
like i'll i'll give my first choice and
look project veritas and rc maxwell the
great journalist over there did a whole
piece on this how was murkowski staffers
that actually left her campaign and then
stood up this other organization to push
through
rank choice voting because she as a
candidate right couldn't directly get
behind it and then after it went in they
went back to the campaign so the idea is
in the general election what will happen
is
republicans will say
i guess i'll vote for murkowski and my
second choice are going to be these
other you know candidates write-ins or
maybe you know maga people but the
democrats will put murkowski as their
fifth choice right so when all of their
people lose if murkowski is in the lead
she's gonna get all the democrat votes
along with the the establishment votes
so it makes it impossible for
the republicans to get in populists
basically look and i've said this before
and i i don't think yang has it right
you know if you're gonna start a third
party a real third party in this country
you have to do it within the party
structure that's already existing
and there is a third party in this
country and it's called maga that is a
third party it just happens to be inside
the republican party yeah i mean you've
got the the left
bernie party or whatever inside the
democrat party one of the things that's
happening across the country in the
republican party is there are so many
new people getting involved
you know homemakers and small business
people that are deciding freezing
project the precinct project that's
absolutely right and small groups
picking up patriot moms
voices of washington county or voices of
this county people are getting involved
and they are
get going to school board meetings but
many are deciding to run for these
obscure offices because they all matter
and that's the building block of that
future party jack and these are almost
all very conservative principled valued
people that supported donald trump
when people get into local offices like
you're talking about is it the kind of
thing where they have to quit their
their day gig
unfortunately not usually not usually
not for local offices
so how does that work right so you're
you're you just won the primary for
county commissioner is that right
yes and i'm going up against a democrat
in the fall and if i do get elected in
the fall
technically it's a part-time job but
it's a full-time demanding job if you're
going to do your job correctly it does
pay a salary of about 38 000 a year but
you're voting and managing a budget of
nearly 800 million dollars across the
board for the county wow so it takes
a full-time effort to go to meetings to
go to commissions you know there's a
couple dozen commissions that are you
know elderly commission there's women's
commission there's zoning water
commissions those things that you have
to be aware of what's going on and lots
of issues are coming forward and you're
and you're trying to get the job to
manage 800 million dollars for a 30 000
salary this is the challenge of politics
right now that is that is an ince i
could not imagine trying to imagine
manage a budget like that and you
effectively have to do it for free you
have to really really want that job you
got to care about your county your
hometown the future of your kids yeah or
throw it away and just make sure that
some of that millions goes to people you
know no i was just going to say that
that
yeah you're exactly right that in on the
flip side of this for people that aren't
maybe uh already independently wealthy
or have a you know a stable career
outside of this that that's where that's
where bribery and that's where money
comes in because they'll say hey you
know sign off in the zoning board for us
this happened in my hometown with um you
know we lost a golf course to out to a
hospital that nobody wanted and the the
this was this wasn't county level this
was um
township level and they went the the
company went in and just bankrolled a
couple of democrats that wanted that
would vote for the hospital and then got
him on board boom golf course gone
hospital in there you go
and and that's it that's the way this
system works
i remember when i was uh younger i
noticed that all these skate parks that
were popping up were garbage just like
the worst and i just didn't understand
why i was like why are they so bad
because they're the x games they
obviously have good ramps why aren't
those companies making it yeah there was
a community meeting in one of the
neighborhoods
where a local construction company was
like it's going to cost you know half a
million dollars to build this park
and then as the story goes
some guy grabbed his phone and put on
speaker one of the big top tier
companies that makes all the big parks
and they said we can do this for a
hundred that's ridiculous but the city
still went with the guy who said 500.
what i was told was that in many of
these circumstances in the city the
people who build skateparks have no idea
how to build them but they're the
lobbyists they're the companies that
fund the local politicians so when they
come they call up and say look i need a
favor you got the budget to build it we
can build it you know go with us you
know we support you say okay fine what's
the harm it's a construction company
they know how to build a skate park
we'll go with them they're here anyway
then what happens they don't know how to
build a park skate parks are very
specific and you get dangerous garbage
parks and you're wondering why man i got
to tell you they built this one part
that uh they built the dimensions of the
bowl rung so a bowl is like it's like a
like a pool right you've got multiple
you know transition ramps that go around
an edge and they built them so compact
and tight
one guy i remember skating did not know
it was built wrong and if you've been
skating you know most ramps usually are
built correctly so you just ride around
and you know how to make your moves and
he went up to carve between these two
walls and they were built like a 90 like
it was like a wall and he slammed into
it bashed his skull and was left blood
in the ground
that is because
and this is what i'm told
the city decided to go with a crony over
an actual construction company that's
what happens with cronyism you're saying
like with regarding cronyism so like
they'll say uh corporation will be like
we're gonna fund these democrats to make
sure that our skate park gets built so
if you were the county commissioner
would there be other people on the
commission with you it's a five-person
commission
and it's a majority vote that will make
the determination on a budget or an
issue of a purchase for the sheriff's
department like new equipment or for the
fire department because it's fire it's
fire and rescue
ems sheriff's department those are all
under the county and your role be one of
five one of five
so how does that how does that work when
people vote like it says vote for five
county commissioners there's a big list
right
wow that's crazy yep all right well good
luck so you you are but you're not just
up against one democrat then are you no
no there's multiple democrats so and
yeah
in some ways you could say you're up
against other republicans right because
it's it's a food fight at that point so
what is the top five
it's it's a it's a top five and you know
in washington county tim as you know
it's a heavily republican it was a trump
county by about 61 percent manga country
maga country yep and you know we've got
people that really care about their
their county and the future here and
we've got a great slate of good
candidates across the board but then in
um
i just remember from back home my county
was uh you would have to do you have to
have certain number of minority seats
no there's no requirement for
any identity politicians and i'm i'm
pretty sure washington county sent a
letter requesting to secede from
maryland to join west virginia
yes they did
that's the percentage
yes tim that letter was
sent and received is that like actually
on the table
i mean
it there was it was like three counties
right western maryland well
i find that the succession idea
to be a major distraction from our
ability to actually work on the heart
issues that we have an opportunity to
make progress on
did you see the uh the districts change
with the new census yes
by cutting out basically what what was
it they they had uh the frederick
suburbs in
the the the western uh maryland
congressional district congressional
district for western maryland is the
sixth congressional district and we got
david trone running against neil parrott
in for the
uh congressional seat here
and by the way david trone does not live
within the district okay and you're
allowed to do that you're allowed to do
that here okay and the other issue is
you know the gerrymandering was
challenged in court and it came out a
little bit better for republicans
because of the court cases brought by
neil parrott and others so but we do
have
it's like a republican district now it
wasn't it's still a majority democrat
district because we've got
parts of the dc suburbs this part of
this district that represents all the
way out to the very end of western
maryland wow so
very dissimilar areas wow this is cd
maryland six cd6 maryland maryland sixth
congressional district
yeah
it's uh d plus one wow that's crazy but
it's a much much better opportunity and
it is looked at as a very competitive
race that the republicans can flip this
year
oh wait wait wait
oh it's changed it's still d plus one
but moving forward they've included
frederick in wow
that's it's just crazy to me i mean
you've got people who live in the
panhandle of maryland who are i mean
it's my country
i go driving out there it is all maga
country it's it's basically west
virginia it's rural yet they are are in
what's basically a dc suburb we've got
montgomery county as part of
part of this district wow you guys
mentioned
multiple times say the word magas come
up and jack even mentioned earlier that
it was oh oh honestly
yeah that there is a third political
party in the united states it's maga but
it's just in the republican party so why
don't they break ranks and start another
political party called maga
why would they because people the reason
i've heard in the past is because it no
they need the money they need that
republican money but no they no they
don't they need fame they need
popularity so it's infrastructure yeah
what does that mean
it's it's the infrastructure of what 9
000 different municipalities across the
entire country that do what exactly that
do everything that he's talking about
from the ground up
it's county county commission not county
commissioners but you know washington
county in maryland you've got a central
committee republicans that help organize
recruit develop
precinct
captains recruit precinct leaders
to register voters all of that
infrastructure is gradually being taken
over by maga yes so if i went to a
county i'm sorry i have to issue a
correction it's nuclear ultra maga
thank you
if i so if i wait wait
with with with the side infusion of of
extremist roads right yeah
not just not just the rosary but the
gadsden flag and
betsy ross flag gonzalez flag yeah so if
i want to i love that story by the way
the story of the gonzalez flag that's
crazy you know the story is i looked it
up
it was a small it was a colony of
gonzales they had what they they
requested armaments they got one cannon
and then mexican colonels whatever
showed up and said give us your cannon
and they were like no come and take it
and they held up a flag with their one
little cannon on it like drew a picture
of it it's amazing so great that's all
it was if i went to a county
with my with my you know gazzed and flag
wrapped around me and i was like i'm an
ultra mega nuclear candidate i want to
run they'd be like we don't have the
infrastructure for you because it's all
republican like what
what would be the difference exactly
like how would i have a hard time
getting on the ballot what would be
different
because i'm making youtube videos i got
100 million people that follow me on
youtube for the sake like you remember
when we talked to the mises caucus guys
and they're talking about the
libertarian party and the pragmatists
and then the mises guys come in
basically took the party over
you've got a party there are people in
it who have ideals so basically what
ends up happening is there's a monopoly
on the political on the political
infrastructure between democrats and
republicans and it's it's going to be
impossible for you to compete with you
know you're trying to open a
coffee shop next to a starbucks good
luck bro they got all the they could
subsidize everything democrats can take
money from wealthy districts send it
over to your district and flood the zone
so you can't possibly win unless you've
got a comparably large so instead of
opening a coffee shop you franchise a
coffee bean to open up next to starbucks
and you got to give some of your profits
and so yeah but now you're going to do
things the way you want to do it it's
all money it's all money so it's not
just money
it's also because the united states has
a winner-take-all system and not
proportional representation right and so
this is why you see more multi-party
coalitions in europe or um and there's
different uh different parts of the
world that have proportional
representation because then you can have
uh if a certain amount of people in the
country vote for that party then they
can get on the ballot that's closer to
what you're talking about so ian it's
actually really really simple
there is a third party the way jack
describes it but what happens is you've
got republicans republicans
overwhelmingly share similar values
one day someone comes up and says hey we
all kind of agree that immigration is an
issue
why don't we put that on our agenda list
to fix the border
established republicans are like no
that's bad for my lobbyists it's bad for
my corporate donors or whatever or i
don't agree with it
but one day you wake up to find that 60
percent of your party agrees we should
secure the border all of a sudden now
you're seeing a new a change of the
candidate's style and and and the way
they talk and the ideas they promote
because they have a higher priority on
issues that their party already kind of
cares are they getting marching orders
they're like hey now 60 of the head of
the rnc wants this so then it's it's
it's it's also
a new generation a new generation
entered the political uh entered the
republican party and if you look at you
know someone like me i didn't vote for
trump in 2016 and voted in 2020. but i i
came from the internet the internet
position of like the agriculture and
freedom and liberty and anarchy and
things like that so when you're getting
all these ron paul young people that
grew up on the internet they're not
going to be democrats they're going to
be republicans and then
when they start running you'll see a ron
desantis and the party starts changing
and when you if you go back historically
just for comparison purposes you know in
the late 1950s and early 60s you know
the republican party you know after
eisenhower
went into the dark ages and you know
minority in in the house of
representatives
you know we had democratic presidents
but we had a revolution within the
republican party
it started with conservative writers and
thinkers it led to barry goldwater
running he lost
really badly
but it provided the seed corn for what
became ronald reagan and the ronald
reagan revolution it took
20 years
but they took over the party
from
the establishment we're going through
the same metamorphosis here in my
judgment
well keep in mind that but people always
talk about you know the barry watergate
book over being blown out but that's
also because that was one year after
uh the jfk assassination and i think
that had a lot more to do with it than
any specific ideology thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there